hi I'm Emily Heller and this is an
@midnight
master class now when I'm not
entertaining I love to entertain at home
with a dinner party and I'm going to
teach you how to impress your dinner
party guests all you need is a regular
cloth dinner napkin and an adventure
spirit you're going to lay it flat out
on the table at this point you should
maybe tell your guests like hey guys I
invited Marilyn Monroe and they'll be
like what are you talking about and
you'll be like just wait you're going to
grab two corners like this fold them
right to the middle crease like that
this is a trick that my dad taught me by
the end of this you're going to know
that that's bad the next thing you do is
you grab the other two corners you fold
them toward the middle or halfway down
you guys please don't lose hope now grab
the middle right here and fold it up
like that the next part the trickiest
part but oh boy is this going to be
worth it grab with your left hand just
the corner careful not to grab the
napkin in the middle and connect it to
the other part on the other side same on
the right just use your fingers I think
that was implied now in one swift motion
you're going to pull them apart
and hold it against your body creating a
brassiere Marilyn Monroe is at the
dinner party and that's going to leave
your guests saying wow this is
definitely a dinner party also cook food
this has been NAT midnight masterclass
you
[Music]